la nuit tombe vite sous la main mais je
suis pas fan
ma
boissons
l'espèce
l'histoire de l'aviation la conquête de
l'univers génération spatiale cette fois
tout était en mauges partions pour la
lune
il ne s'agissait pas seulement d'essayer
nous allions faire débarquer un être
humain sur un autre astre pour la
première fois si ce vol réussi
l'homme sera plus condamné à vivre sur
la terre il y aura fait son premier pas
vers les étoiles
ça paraissait impossible
c'était une entreprise incroyablement
risqué pour ajouté
je m'y étais préparé depuis longtemps
comme tout le monde
pourtant quand le lem s'est posé sur la
lune
je suis resté sans voix tout ce que j'ai
pu prononcer été volé
après avoir arrêté le moteur vérifier
que tout était normal et un la plupart
des instruments de bord neil et moi nous
nous sommes regardés et des jeux lui a
donné une tape dans le dos à cet instant
nous nous sommes rendu compte que nous
avions réalisé ce dont l'humanité rêvait
depuis si longtemps
c'est nous qui avions la chance d'avoir
été choisi pour mener à bien cette
merveilleuse
cela semblait presque incroyable
l'homme venait de se poser sur la lune
était ce la réalité
où était ce le produit de notre
imagination il n'y a plus de sens tant
dans de la terre à la lune
jules verne le décrivit un voyage est un
amant semblable à celui d'apollo 11
trois explorateurs barbie ken hardane et
mcnicoll partait dans l'espace à l'aide
d'un canon située en floride à 160 km de
cap canaveral leur vaisseau s'appelait
columbia d' les membres de l'équipage
d'apollo 11 avait baptisé le leurre
columbia la science-fiction
deviendrait-elle réalité la science
fiction a vraiment constitué le
fondement du voyage dans l'espace
presque tous les ingénieurs qui se sont
intéressés au voyage dans l'espace qui
l'ont rendu possible que dark souls
monde et tous les autres presque tous
étaient les passionnés de science et
espace vie technologies et réalisations
objectifs précis et 10 passes 10
connaissance aussi vision de l'avenir et
désir de franchir de nouvelles
frontières
les auteurs de science fiction nous ont
permis de concevoir ses nouvelles
frontières
il ya certaines analogies avec de la
terre à la lune de jules verne
ses héros sont eux aussi partis de
floride
évidemment il utilisé un canon alors que
nous nous sommes servis d'une fusée mais
nous sommes partis de floride aussi leur
vaisseau était à doper le nôtre un
vaisseau spatial
mais les deux et des faits d'aluminium
il avait trois personnes à bord et nous
aussi bien sur jules verne c'était la
science fiction en était ce vraiment
depuis que les hommes rêvent d'accéder
aux mystères de la voûte céleste
les voyage dans la lune ou vers les
étoiles ont toujours fasciné leur
imagination
c'est un enchaînement bien connu tout
d'abord l'esprit imaginer puis une passe
au stade de la réalisation
on l'a plusieurs fois constaté avec la
science fiction
d'abord une idée apparaît puis elle
passe à l'état de dessin il se
transforme ensuite en métal en
composants électroniques en propre
ergols et en tout ce qu'il faut pour
qu'un rêve devienne une réalité
au début les mythes et les légendes se
transmettait oralement de génération en
génération
puis il fut retranscrit sur papier par
des auteurs tels que swift wells et
jules verne
enfin avec les progrès du cinéma on a pu
produire des miracles sur l'écran comme
une femme dans la lune
destination lune ou base sur la lune la
science fiction est le précurseur de la
science enfin pense que les
scientifiques rêvent de science fiction
il s'enlise
on voit sur les écrans tu as besoin
d'intérioriser finissent pas dire un
jour et si on essayait
ce n'est que lorsqu'on eu la possibilité
de voir la lune avec un télescope en
1609 que la science commença à
démystifier l'astre que le poète chez
les nommait la clarté et rentes ou la
claire coquette du ciel pendant des
siècles la lune a plus inspiré les
poètes que les scientifiques
on savait qu erasme avait tort de croire
qu'elle était faite de fromage vers bab
mais jusqu'à ce que le premier de nos
engins se pose à sa surface
nous ignorions toujours de quoi elle
était faite certains engins inhabitée
avait pris des photographies mais il
restait encore bien des doutes
c'est alors qu'arrive à apollo ce fut la
plus grande mobilisation en terme de
personne de technologie et de courage
jamais vu par temps de paix mais apollo
11 n'était que le début de l'exploration
de la lune par l'homme
le 18 novembre 1969 sous le commandement
de pete conrad apollo 12 allait se poser
dans l'océan des tempêtes
conrad et son équipier alan bean fear2
promenade d'un peu moins de 4 heures
chacune sur la lune
puis ce fut apollo xiii qui décolle à le
11 avril 1970 à 13h13
deux jours plus tard le 13 avril alors
qu'il se préparait à entrer sur orbite
autour de la lune
jim lovell et son équipage durent faire
face à l'explosion d'un réservoir
d'oxygène du module de commande au cours
des 60 minutes qui ont suivi l'explosion
la plupart d'entre nous ont cru que les
membres de l'équipage étaient perdus
comment allons nous faire pour les
ramener sur terre heureusement
l'explosion est arrivé au moment le plus
opportun
ce dont je ne m'étais pas rendu compte
que le module lunaire était encore
arrimé au module de commande et nous
nous en sommes servis comme d'une
chaloupe de sauvetage
son moteur nous a permis de nous mettre
sur la bonne trajectoire
ça n'a pas été facile de piloter car il
a fallu traîner le module de commande
le module lunaire n'était pas conçu pour
voler attaché à une telle masse nous
sommes restés sur une corde raide
jusqu'au retour au centre de contrôle
nous avons commencé à mettre un plan sur
pied dans tout le pays des gens nous ont
apporté leur aide
chaque minute chaque heure durant
lesquelles nous réussissions à maintenir
l'équipe agen vie à nous permettait
d'envisager de nouvelles options après
l'explosion
l'astuce de l'équipage et des jeux au
sol a été d'utiliser le module lunaire
comme une chaloupe de sauvetage
c'était une idée complètement folle
apollo 14 allait permettre à alan
shepard de se promener et de jouer au
golf sur la lune un tonique que c'est
quelque chose d'aller dans la dune
quand je regarde le ciel et que je peux
voir à tous ceux qui forment le droit et
la l'endroit où je me suis posée où j'ai
genou gauche tissu jusqu'ici je suis le
seul je n'ai eu en tire conscience de ce
que nous faisions qu'après que nous
soyons poser à nous sommes sortis nous
nous sommes promenés nous avons installé
les appareils et c'est seulement ensuite
que nous avons et regarder la terre sans
que le modèle à nos gènes et voir cette
planète 4 grosse que la lune est pleine
de distinguer le plan des banquises le
plot des océans c'était un spectacle
magna ça m'a fait quelque chose j'en ai
pleuré voir cette planète si belle
l'endroit où j'habitais et où tous mes
amis ce travail
pour récolter les trésors cachés sur la
lune les membres d'équipage d'apollo 15
16 et 17 ont utilisé des véhicules
motorisés
ils on ramassait des échantillons du sol
lunaire et ont effectué des expériences
scientifiques qui nous ont permis d'en
savoir plus non seulement en ce qui
concerne la lune mais aussi en ce qui
concerne la terre
on
cette période ressemblait à une sorte
d'âge d'or de l'exploration spatiale
puis les mission d'apollo sur la lune
ont pris fin jacques schmitt membres
d'équipage d'apollo 17 fut le premier
géologue est l'un des deux derniers
hommes à aller sur la lune
quand j'ai regardé la lune pour la
dernière fois à travers le hublot du
module lunaire du challenger
j'ai vu ce ciel d'un noir d'or et les
montagnes illuminé plus loin j'ai une
sensation de jubilation
vous savez que nous avions fait du bon
boulot tout ce qui était prévu et même
plus mais j'étais aussi un peu triste
car nous étions la dernière mission
apollo
aujourd'hui douze hommes ont marché sur
la lune
ce fut un tournant historique pour
l'humanité mais on peut se demander s'il
valait la peine d'investir tellement
d'argent et de prendre tant de risques
pour aller marcher sur la lune et
rapporter quelques échantillons du sol
lunaire
la première chose que nous avons
apprises grâce à paulo c'est
qu'effectivement on peut y aller et
qu'on peut aussi retourner quand on le
voudra tout le monde est conscient de ça
aujourd'hui l'une des choses les plus
importantes que nous avons apprises et
c'est l'âge de la robe nous avons pu
savoir qu'elle était rouge géologique de
la laine
ça ferait l'objet d'une controverse
avant on a découvert que la lune était
très vieille elle remonte presque au
début du système solaire
l'autre chose qu'on emprise sur la lune
c'est comment elle s'est formée la
plupart des scientifiques pensent
aujourd'hui que lors de la création du
système solaire
un astéroïde est entré en collision avec
la terre peu après sa formation ce qui a
provoqué l'expulsion de gaz de vapeur et
de débris qui sont allés se mettre sur
orbite et se sont agrégés en assad élite
une analyse scientifique du sol lunaire
a révélé la présence d'un isotope de
l'hélium l'hélium 3 dont certains
pensent qu'il pourrait remplacer les
combustibles fossiles comme source
d'énergie sur la terre
utilisé dans les centrale de fusion
comme combustible l'hélium 3 ne
produirait aucun effet significatif sur
l'environnement
le problème c'est que nous n'avons pas
sur terre mais il y en a une bonne
réserve sur la foi mais apollo apporter
autre chose que des découvertes
scientifiques
pour certains il a donné de nouvelles
perspectives à l'humanité et à la
planète entière sur la lune nous savions
pas ce que nous apprendrions je pense
que ce que nous y avons appris le plus
important est à propos de lui-même en
voyant cette petite baie bleue dans
l'espace c'est vrai la terre paraît
fragile vue de l'espace
on ne voit pas l'adversaire elle
réfléchit la lumière du soleil
c'est un petit astre très fragile ce qui
est significatif
c'est le symbole du mouvement écologique
c'est une photographie de la terre vue
de l'espace
les voyages dans l'espace ont changé
notre conception de la terre pour la
première fois nous l'avons vu dans son
ensemble on peut même dire que cette
photographie de la terre vue de l'espace
est ce que l'ère des voyages spatiaux
nous a apporté de plus important
certains astronautes ont une vraie
révélation
ils se sont rendus compte que la terre
et d'une partie intégrante de l'univers
on ne voit aucune frontière quand on est
l'une des choses les plus importantes
que nous ayons apprises dans l'espace
nous concerne nous mêmes nous vivons sur
une planète qui grouillent de vie mais
qui n'est pas indépendante ne nous
connaissons pas très bien et nous
connaissons mal la planète sur laquelle
nous vivons et les formes de vie dont
nous dépendons ses voyages me donne
l'occasion de nous regarder depuis
l'espace
nous allons mieux nous connaître c'est
important pour les générations futures
la mission apollo était terminée mais la
conquête de l'espace
elle continué il eut d'abord skylab
réalisation avant l'heure de ce qui nous
attend dans l'avenir la vie et le
travail dans l'espace
lancé au printemps 1973 le laboratoire
spatial skylab était aussi grand qu'une
maison de six pièces
le premier équipage a passé presque un
mois à bord
le deuxième est resté en orbite pendant
59 jours et le troisième 84 jours les
équipages ont accumulé des données sur
l'environnement terrestre et effectuer
des recherches sur l'effet d'une
apesanteur prolongé sur le corps humain
je pense que skylab a été le programme
le plus important de la nasa
c'est la première fois qu'on se procurer
directement des retombées pour les
enrique on a recherché les investisseurs
d'arrivée nous avons effectué des
expériences dans le domaine de la
recherche fondamentale de la biologie
des ressources terrestres de
l'astronomie ainsi qu'une série
d'expériences annexes principalement des
essais de fabrication dans l'espace mais
les vols qui suivirent celui d'apollo 17
ne furent pas tous de nature
scientifique pendant l'été 1975 eu lieu
la mission apollo soyouz surnommée la
poignée de main dans l'espace les
cosmonautes soviétiques et les
astronautes américains se donnait pour
la première fois rendez vous dans
l'espace
quoi
ma mission à bono soyouz souhaite une
mission intéressante du point de vue
humain il avait été décidée à l'avant ce
que nous apprendrions à part les russes
et que les soviétiques à prendre et à
parler anglais
on pensait que c'était une façon de
minimiser les risques d'erreurs la
collaboration avec les soviétiques nous
a beaucoup plu nous avons eu des
problèmes d'interface pour certains
instruments donc par ailleurs ils
n'étaient pas habitués à notre
comportement social ouvert à faire
circuler les informations comme nous
pensions que c'était nécessaire au
succès de la mission
nous avons eu des discussions animées
mais tout s'est bien passé
ils sont devenus des amis et le sont
toujours
le 21 avril 1981
vingt ans jour pour jour après le vol
sur orbite de youri gagarine commença au
centre spatial kennedy
le compte à rebours de la première
navette spatiale américaine à columbia
john young et robert crippen s'élevaient
dans un vacarme assourdissant
produit par les 3500 tonnes de poussée
d'un engin d'un type nouveau
à partir de 80 kilomètres au dessus du
sol
young écrit peine commence la manoeuvre
destinée à placer le premier avion fusée
sur orbite à 200 km de la terre pour y
effectuer 36 révolution
par la suite des spationautes du monde
entier seront envoyés dans l'espace pour
des vols qu'aucun d'entre nous lira le
départ et un moment extraordinaire
c'est l'expérience la plus marquante que
j'ai jamais s'être non pas à cause de la
violence mais parce que c'est quelque
chose de totalement nouveau
on ressent d'intenses vibrations pendant
les deux premières minutes puis d'un
seul coup tout devient calme quand les
boosters se détache et que les moteurs
principaux prennent le relais c'est une
expérience extraordinaire de voler dans
l'espace
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il existe des mots
pour la décrire ce n'est pas simplement
la sensation de ne plus avoir de poids
qui est étonnante
tout ce qu'on voit là haut nous rappelle
notre insignifiance
quand on est en haut on a l'impression
que c'est normal mais lorsqu'on
réfléchit à toute la préparation à toute
l'énergie qu'il a fallu pour vous y
amener c'était étonnant étonnant que
nous autres petites créatures bipèdes
ayons réussi à maîtriser l'énergie
suffisante pour y parvenir
quand j'ai vu pour la première fois la
terre depuis l'espace
je me suis rendu compte combien c'est
quelque chose d'unique et comme elle
constitue une petite communauté
pour moi c'est suffisant pour continuer
l'exploration spatiale
pour moi personnellement le vol dans
l'espace a été une expérience très fort
est tous sur le plan émotionnel et
psychologique voire la terre comme très
peu de gens jusqu'à aujourd'hui ont eu
l'occasion de le faire
regardez la courbure terrestre se rendre
compte de l'isolément de la terre dans
l'espace
c'est le genre d'expérience qui marque
savourant vous inspire d'autres pensées
ça m'a fait réfléchir à la création et
au créateur d'une façon que je ne
mettais pas imaginer
c'est une expérience très fade les vols
de la navette ont non seulement fait
avancer la conquête de l'espace
mais ils se sont aussi révélés d'une
grande utilité pour toute l'humanité
ils ont permis de mettre sur orbite des
satellites de communication pour le
compte d'état et d'entreprises privées
de lancer des engins d'explorations
interplanétaire comme galilée et
magellan qu'ils nous enverront des
images et des informations sur jupiter
et sur vénus et grâce à elle des
recherches scientifiques inestimable ont
été effectués dont les résultats
bénéficieront à tout le genre humain
mais innues de céder drame 28 janvier
1986 la navette challenger d'école pour
son dixième voyage dans l'espace
parmi les membres de l'équipage se
trouvaient christa mac auliffe à qui
avait été décerné le titre de professeur
de l'espace 73 secondes après son
décollage de cap canaveral la fusée
explose tuant tout les membres de
l'équipage
une fois de plus des hommes et une femme
à ces intrépides pour tenter de réaliser
leurs rêves ne se lancerait plus jamais
dans l'espace
après l'accident de challenger bien plus
de gens dans le monde se sont senties
concernées mais lorient d'imaginer nous
vous avons ressenti nos pertes
considérables
les conditions bien mais je crois que
tout le pays que le monde entier s'est
senti concerné presque trois ans allait
passer avant qu'une autre navette ne
parte dans l'espace trois années pendant
lesquelles les boosters ont été revus et
de nouvelles mesures de sécurité ont été
mises au point trois années qui ont
permis de se refaire un optimisme est de
regagner une certaine confiance dans le
programme mais en avril 1990 ce nouvel
optimisme
allez devoir faire face à une autre
déception malgré un lancement réussi
la navette discovery mis dans l'espace
le premier observatoire de la nasa
la communauté scientifique avait du mal
à retenir son impatience devant les
perspectives de découverte les
chercheurs prévoyait que l'oeil énorme
double pour est scruté 97% de l'univers
connu qu'il serait en mesure de détecter
des objets 50 fois plus petit que ce que
peuvent détecter les télescopes
terrestres
depuis galilée aucun progrès de cette
ampleur dans les possibilités de scruter
les limites de notre univers n'avait été
réalisée une fois de plus la science
fiction allait devenir réalité mais il
se passa une chose totalement inattendue
lors des tests on s'aperçut que les
images transmises par hubble était floue
trois ans plus tard seulement le vétéran
story meuse grève et son équipage serait
en mesure d'aller réparer le télescope
ça ressemble et un spectacle de
chorégraphie sorte de ballet dans lequel
on sait où chacun de ses doigts se
trouver où il va aller ensuite vous
savez je ne suis pas retournée dans
l'espace depuis 27 ans mais on s'attend
à vivre des moments intenses et c'en
était un
tout comme certains de mes autres vols
on a découvert tellement de choix sur
l'endroit nous vivons avec bell
c'est inestimable de connaître l'âge de
l'univers cette taille ce sont des
questions que l'homme se pose depuis
qu'il existe
une fois de plus ce qui était hier un
rêve est devenu réalité
l'homme est capable d'observer des
mondes qu'il y a quelques années
seulement on ne pouvait se concevoir que
par l'imagination mais il reste
certaines questions
dans quelle direction aller comment
doit-on s'organiser les opinions sur ces
sujets varient à bas depuis 10 ans je
défends l'idée d'une base lunaire où je
pense que ça constitue une poursuite
naturelle de l'exploration de l'espace
je pense que pour l'avenir prévisible il
faut d'abord lancer une station spatiale
à partir de là nous verrons si nous
pouvons aller plus lourd que pour ce qui
est du futur le plus proche
l'homme doit aller sur mars c'est
l'astre présentant le plus grand intérêt
sur lequel nous ne voyons pas encore
allé alors que nous pouvons le faire
on peut aussi avoir envie d'aller sur
alfa du centaure
mais la plupart des gens pensent qu'il
faut aller sur mars
chaque chose en son temps moi aussi
j'aimerais bien pouvoir aller tout de
suite sur alfa du centaure la plupart de
ceux qui ont encore en mémoire l'époque
du programme apollo sont d'avis qu'il
faut retourner sur la lune et y établir
des bases pour l'avenir immédiat
je pense que nous devrions retourner
dans la lune et établir des bases mêmes
petites fautes encore se permettre de
faire des erreurs a deux choix de le
faire si on envoie des hommes sur mars
et qui se produit une erreur là bas
inutile de tenter quoi que ce soit pour
les sauver de plus nous avons à peine
commencé à explorer la lune il ya
beaucoup à faire
il y a de bonnes raisons d'établir une
base lunaire
la première c'est de produire de
l'énergie qu'on utilisera sur la terre
en produisant de l'énergie pollue
inévitablement avec une base lunaire on
pourrait récupérer un isotope de
l'hélium 3 qu'on trouve dans le sous sol
dans la ville
m3 est le matériau idéal pour produire
une énergie de questions sur les effets
de l'environnement sont négligeables
si l'on cherchait une source d'énergie
de remplacement en combustibles fossiles
dans l'avenir avec hélium 3 on a une
alternative qui permettrait aussi de
respecter l'environnement
en plus des réserves d'hélium 3 existant
sur la lune
les scientifiques pensent que le
rayonnement solaire que l'on renverrait
sur terre constitue une autre source
d'énergie alternative fiable et peu
coûteuse dans l'espace on trouve de
l'énergie solaire en abondance et de
manière tout à fait fiables sur terre
l'énergie solaire n'est pas fiable
elle est très coûteuse alors pourquoi ne
pas aller sur la lune y récolter
l'énergie qu'on trouve la banque entité
depuis un point l'eau nous savons que la
matière dont est constituée la lune est
une matière idéale pour la fabrication
de panneaux solaires
on pourrait prendre une certaine
quantité de sol lunaire la faire fondre
elalamy liant une faille très fine et en
faire les cellules solaires
d'autres personnes pensent qu'en
établissant des centrales solaires ou
des mines d'hélium 3 sur la lune on
irait trop vite et qu'il faut d'abord
envoyé une station dans l'espace
non il n'est pas question d'abandonner
le projet de station spatiale et de
retourner et coloniser la lune
nous sommes déjà les noms la lune ce
qu'il faut faire c'est construire une
station spatiale internationale et c'est
ce que nous allons faire avec 13 autres
pays la da le japon 10 pays d'europe et
la rue nous la lancerons en 1997 il faut
arrêter avec les utopies et les
controverses
je pense que la prochaine étape dans
l'exploration de l'espace et la station
spatiale ça vous donnera la possibilité
de mener des recherches de façon
continue et aussi longtemps qu'on le
voudra l'installation de l'homme dans
l'espace qui est la raison d'être de la
recherche spatiale ne peut pas
s'effectuer sans existence dans station
spatiale il faut avoir l'expérience de
vivre et de travailler dans l'espace en
ce qui concerne l'avenir proche
je crois que l'exploration de l'espace
passe par l'établissement d'une station
spatiale nous allons beaucoup faire
progresser nos connaissances en envoyant
des hommes dans l'espace pendant un
certain temps
pas seulement dans le domaine
scientifique comme pour la médecine en
mettant au point des vaccins contre
certaines maladies mais aussi en
regardant la terre d'un autre point de
vue
il y à aussi mars
bien sûr la mystérieuse planète rouge
aucune autre planète du système solaire
n'a autant fasciné l'imagination de
l'homme que la planète mars
nous irons c'est comme si vous me
demandiez si le soleil se lèvera demain
c'est la même chose
nous en avons les moyens
et l'homme est toujours aller là où il
en avait les moyens mars est une bonne
destination
c'est une planète qui ressemble la terre
son histoire nous apprendra sûrement
beaucoup sur le futur de la terre c'est
une bonne destination pour les hommes
nous avons étudié la possibilité d'une
présence de vie sur mars mais nous
n'avons pas trouvé sur les deux sites
ont été explorées mais qu'en est-il
d'une vie qui se serait éteinte pendant
des milliards d'années il y a eu de
l'eau sur mars et la température était
plus élevé comme la terre à son début la
vie est bien apparu sur la terre est
elle apparue sur mars
y at il des fossiles nous devons donc
aller sur mars pour trouver une réponse
on ce qu'il ya eu des fleuves sur mars
ils pouvaient avoir doses à 15
kilomètres de large et deux kilomètres
et demi de profondeur
on peut rassembler la volga le rhin et
le mississippi ça ne ressemblerait qu'un
ruisseau à côté qu'est devenue toute
cette eau comment se présente le sous
sol
nous n'en savons rien mais nous savons
qu'il y ait un changement total ce qui
se passe en ce moment sur la terre
ressemble probablement à ce qui s'est
passé que sur route
certains pensent que le premier vol
habité à destination de mars est encore
loin dans l'avenir
c'est une entreprise qui doit attendre
que la technologie rattrape le rêve
d'autres croient que l'homme peut faire
le voyage se poser sur mars et en
revenir avec la technologie actuelle il
existe une théorie appelée mars direct
l'idée est la suivante on en verrait
d'abord un engin inhabitée vers la
planète qui après un voyage de huit mois
larguerait sa charge utile à la surface
de la planète
cette charge utile se transformerait en
usine qui produirait le carburant
nécessaire au retour sur la terre en s'y
prenant bien on peut emporter six tonnes
d'hydrogène de la terre et en fer 108
tonnes de propergol met en oxygène sur
mars c'est un rapport de 1 à 18 ans
fabricant sur mars
le combustible du retour on peut
utiliser pour le voyage aller un engin
assez léger il ne faudrait alors que six
mois pour rejoindre dans ces conditions
il pourrait explorer la surface pendant
un an et demi laissez ensuite leurs
stations sur mars et revenir sur terre
c'est faisable dès aujourd'hui si on
commence la réalisation des projets
maintenant nous y serons dans moins dix
le vol vers mars et moi un objectif
qu'un point de départ
si la contribution de notre génération à
des vols d'exploration plus long qui
aboutiront peut-être à ce qu'il ya de
plus fascinant pour notre imagination
une rencontre avec d'autres mondes base
lunaire station spatiale vol vers mars
les successeurs de wells et de jules
verne nous indique-t-il ce à quoi
ressemblera l'avenir la science-fiction
particulièrement avec les films
influence beaucoup elle fait travailler
l'imagination des gens le public a aimé
la série star trek parce qu'elles
étaient suffisamment près pour accepter
l'idée d'un voyage dans l'espace
jen rodenberry le créateur de star trek
était un de mes amis il siégeait au
conseil d'administration de la société
en réussissant à captiver l'intérêt du
public je crois qu'il a plus fait pour
l'exploration spatiale que n'importe qui
depuis trente ans la série a fait
accepter le mot science fiction
facilement le public s'est passionné
pour tout ce qui touchait à
l'exploration de l'espace
il ya des auteurs de science fiction
contemporain arthur clarke ray bradbury
un cinéaste jean roucas et un peuple
comme maicon il influence l'imagination
des gens qui les lisent ou qu'ils voient
ce qu'il faut que l'homme choisissent la
base lunaire la station spatiale ou le
voyage vers mars
la conquête de l'espace continuera
je crois que le but de l'exploration
spatiale c'est la colonisation de
l'espace
l'objectif ultime de notre société et de
se répandre dans l'univers dans le passé
l'exploration s'est faite par voie de
mer les sociétés reposer sur les voyages
maritimes la civilisation doit
aujourd'hui s'adapter à l'ère des
voyages dans l'espace dans un avenir
proche
d'ici un ou deux siècles des enfants
naîtront dans des colonies humaines de
l'espace et ne mettront jamais le pied
sur le problème où les hommes vont
coloniser le système solaire
cela ne se passera pas aussi vite que
j'aurais aimé mais ça arrivera bien plus
tôt que la plupart des gens le croient
parce que les âmes sont des petits êtres
curieux et qu'ils veulent toujours
savoir ce qui se passe de l'autre côté
une fois établie dans l'espace
il nous restera à éclaircir un autre
thème de science fiction
existe-t-il d'autres formes de vie
intelligente
sommes-nous seuls dans l'univers
ou y at il d'autres formes
d'intelligence
c'est une question fondamentale pour le
genre humain elle remonte à l'époque des
cavernes où l'homme a pour la première
fois rencontrés autour de lui d'autres
formes d'intelligence amical ou hostiles
aujourd'hui nous demandons si on n'a pas
d'autre dans l'univers et où elles sont
sont elles déjà venu en voir reste-t-il
des traces de leurs visites vont nous
rendre compte de leurs existences sont
des questions fascinantes la meilleure
solution pour trouver la réponse c'est
d'y aller voir l'important c'est d'y
aller
quel que soit ce qu'on découvrira je
crois que l'univers serait un endroit
plus intéressant et plus chaleureux s'il
existe d'autres ancêtres il le partage
avec moby moi je suis persuadé que
l'univers regorge de vie qu'elle
foisonnent entre les étoiles et les
galaxies
c'est une perspective fascinante je n'ai
aucun doute là dessus
l'univers est trop vaste trop mystérieux
trop magique
on doit continuer de chercher s'il
existe d'autres êtres que nous il ya
d'autres planètes de notre système
solaire la voie lactée notre galaxie on
compte quelque chose quand 100 milliards
il y à des billions de l'acsi on a
calculé que si seulement un pour cent de
chaque centaine de millions d'étoilés de
planètes qu'il existe une forme de vie
sur seulement 1 % d'entre elles que
cette forme de v est intelligente sur
seulement 1 % d'entre elles l'estimation
la plus faible des formes de vie
intelligente et assistants et de plus de
dix mille milliards dix mille milliards
de mondes où il existe une forme de vie
intelligente
il suffit de savoir comment leur rendre
visite
la recherche a déjà commencé le ceti un
organisme qui recherchent les formes de
vie intelligente extraterrestre
utilisent des radiotélescopes pour
capter les signes venant de l'espace
pour savoir s'il existe d'autres formes
de vie dans l'univers
nous cherchons des signaux radio une
technologie extraterrestre aurait pu
émettre soit pour attirer notre
attention soit pour son propre usage
c'est totalement scientifique ce n'est
pas la science fiction c'est bien plus
concret que star trek
il est très possible que des signaux
radio parcours les énormes distance qui
nous sépare des autres étoiles et que
nous puissions détecter leurs traces
avec les grand radiotélescope et les
systèmes de décryptage dont nous
disposons aujourd'hui
j'espère qu'un jour le ceti signalera
qu'il a capté un signal venant de
l'espace allô allô à cause des énormes
distance la communication est difficile
mais grâce au seti nous sommes en mesure
de recevoir des signaux au lieu de
simplement en maîtres au hasard et
d'attendre qu'on nous réponde
quelqu'un va peut-être nous re
téléphoner un de ces jours je l'espère
si nous voulons un jour découvrir les
mystères de notre univers nous devons
nous mettre en route mais deux choses
nous sépare des étoiles l'une est la
volonté l'autre le moyen la première
dépend du pouvoir de nos rêves
la seconde du pouvoir de la technologie
à l'heure actuelle tous mes efforts au
laboratoire de pour poste variations
tendent à prouver un autre moyen que les
fusées à réaction chimique pour
s'arracher à la pesanteur et voyager
dans l'espace
j'ai quelques idées qui pourraient nous
le permettre et que j'essaie de faire
avancer mais il faut que vous sachiez il
y à d'autres moyens de voyager dans
l'espace que les fusées à réaction
chimique
ce n'est pas un hasard si les idées du
docteur for words ressemble à de la
science fiction
elle constitue le fondement de ses
romans mais ce sont aussi des idées
scientifiques bien réel comme le concept
d'un nouveau type d'engin propulsé par
antimatière jusqu'à présent pour
arracher une masse à la pesanteur
terrestre
on a utilisé un grand réservoir de
carburant sur lequel ont placé une
petite capsule comme par exemple la
navette au décollage elle se trouve tout
en haut de son énorme réservoir de
carburant étaient debout ce n'est la
masse de carburant actuellement
nécessaire et de 60 à 100 fois
supérieure à celle de la charge utile
alors qu'avec de l'antimatière elle ne
serait que deux fois supérieur soit une
quantité équivalente à celle d'un grain
de sel
on pourrait faire décoller la navette et
toute sa charge avec 3 mg dont il
matière
si on pouvait en fabriquer bien sûr avec
10 mg on pourrait l'envoyer jusqu'à la
lune et il suffirait de 20 ou 30 mg pour
l'envoyer sur mars à toute allure
une autre technique utopique et pourtant
rationnelle du docteur for world
permettre de voyager dans l'espace et la
voile solaire la voile solaire et d'une
immense feuille d'aluminium déployer
dans l'espace quand on déploie dans
l'espace une surface réfléchissante
comme de l'aluminium les rayons du
soleil vienne lavaltrie et rebondissent
dessus en rebondissant la lumière
imprime au miroir une très légère
poussée doux l'analogie avec une voile
mais comme il n'ya pas de frottement
dans l'espace et que le processus de
rayonnement solaire a continué la
poussée s'accumulent petit à côté d'une
semaine on pourrait aller plus vite que
dans la porte de kehl fusé des
scientifiques visionnaire nous montre de
nouveau que la science fiction peut
devenir réalité que la technologie
nécessaire à l'exploration de l'espace
intergalactique passe de la théorie à la
réalisation mais aurons-nous la volonté
l'imagination le goût de l'aventuré
nécessaire à poursuivre ce que nous
avons entrepris avec apollo 11
peut-être que les auteurs de
science-fiction essaie de nous faire
comprendre qu'il y a encore beaucoup à
découvrir toute la galaxie
toutes les galaxies de l'univers d'un
chaque galaxie
il ya des milliards des toiles dont un
bon nombre sont semblables à la nôtre
d'autres mondes d'autres sociétés nous
n'avons même pas encore commencé à
étudier
nous en sommes juste des baies il s'agit
à nouveau de frontières nous ne savons
pas ce que nous allons trouver là bas
mais nous avons ce désir profond
d'arriver jusqu'au sommet d'un mental
atteindre les étoiles comprendre
l'univers
toutes ces raisons je crois que
l'humanité continuera d'explorer
l'univers
elliott a dit nous continuerons
d'explorer sans relâche et à la fin nous
retrouverons à notre point de départ
comme si nous venions pour la première
fois
j'aime cette citation car elle a une
double dimension il y à l'exploration en
quête de savoir et le retour avec la
sagesse pour le bien de la planète
on va voir parce que c'est là une
lycéenne a mis en légende d'un dessin
qu'elle a fait pour la nasa
nous ne serons jamais si nous n'y allons
pas les êtres humains sont curieux de
nature
si nous n'allons pas voir nous ne
connaîtrons jamais la réponse la têt et
- le centre de la vie dans l'univers que
le berceau de la vie
c'est là que tout a commencé mais une
taille qui ne va pas au delà de son
berceau est incomplète
c'est notre destin d'aller porter la
graine de la vie dans les étoiles
cela s'est passé en floride il ya 25 ans
sur un cap appelé cap canaveral c'est
d'ici qu'est partie la plus grande
aventure de l'humanité et s'est dit
'tiens que partiront les prochains
voyageurs vers l'inconnu vivons
maintenant dans l'ère des voyages dans
l'espace
une aire que la technologie a vendu
magique et nous avons rendez vous avec
notre destin à au delà de la lune dans
les étoiles
on
non
pour
on